now you would not use binomial theorem
for a question like this you could if
you really want to be seen there for a
long time
why wouldn't use binomial theorem for
this what will you end up with when you
expand you'll get this is 2007 right
come on think Pascal's triangle how many
times you're gonna get you're gonna get
eight terms do you really want to go all
through that way I mean no one remembers
the seventh row of Pascal's triangle
anyway so this is going to be a pain you
do not want to expand this so instead
you should learn from what you use back
in differentiation to think wait this
looks like something familiar if you
were asked to differentiate something
like this it would be quite
straightforward and because integration
is very much to do with the reverse of
differentiation you can use this
knowledge right so normally what would
you do if you were differentiating you
would multiply by the power and then
you'd reduce the power by one we're
integrating so we're going to do
everything in Reverse okay we are going
to instead of divide sorry instead of
reduced we're going to increase the
power right so I should end up with this
yes powers going up what I do in this
look at a multiply I'm going to divide
now that's nice for that power but this
is not just differentiation this is the
chain rule right so what I'm missing
there's the inside right when you
differentiate something with the chain
rule you multiply by the inside while
I'm not differentiating I am integrating
so instead of multiplying by the inside
derivative I should divine in this case
it's a three yes are you happy with that
I can simplify that in a second but
before I do something is missing namely
the constant of integration because of
course this is indefinite
okay now just a quick mental check if
you've got that on 24 on the bottom
let's just tighten it up will we be able
to successfully returned to the original
integrand if we differentiate does it
work out yes it should right I don't say
in the afternoon but we got there you
multiply by the eight which cancels down
here you're also going to multiply by
the three which gets rid of your
denominator entirely your power reduces
everything is fine okay
now in cases like this we can pretty
much do this in our heads it's
sufficiently small that your brain
doesn't get sort of fizzled out by
having too many numbers all together in
your memory but when you have a look at
some other questions it rapidly sort of
grows out of control so I'm going to
give you two examples okay here's the
first one and here we go looks like this
okay so let's have a look at this guy
now you can use exactly the same piece
of knowledge that we used over here to
integrate this guy you can integrate it
but it looks gross right like it looks
terrible I suppose we could if we wanted
to we could do binomial up here you'd
get out there's a power of three so how
many terms will you get up you'll get
one two three four terms that's somewhat
manageable you could divide everything
through by the square root of x and then
you just have a bunch of terms you could
integrate that it would be fine okay
but we can use the chain rule here it's
much faster not only is it faster if I
change this three back into a seven it
would really be the only practical
reasonable way to do it okay but at the
moment it's kind of like hmm what I do
with this thing I don't really know
where to begin there's not just like
simple numbers that I can shuffle around
okay so therefore I need my other color
I want to introduce to you this kind of
question we'll get given to you guys as
to unit and extension one students as a
particular format I don't have a fancy
name for it so I'm literally going to
give you the words that will appear in
the question that will give you a cue as
to oh it's this kind of question right
so you will most often see an integral
like this paired up with these words and
we see these in HSC questions all the
time you get given an expression and
part one is to differentiate that
expression part two is then on the basis
of that differentiation just did now can
you integrate this thing that otherwise
looks quite intimidating and messy okay
so where are we going to begin so if you
want you can call this part 1 the
differentiate that you're going to be
asked to deal with is this guy
[Music]
so do that right sorry there's a number
of that's men on the road okay now
because I'm differentiating I'm much
more comfortable with this and you've
been practicing chain rule for some time
so you should be able to help me out
with this right would you like to do the
inside or the outside first inside sure
why not order doesn't matter in this
case when we do the inside this is X to
the 1/2 plus one not a trick question
what difference is that plus one make no
difference doesn't doesn't influence the
derivative role because you're just
vertically shifting up and down and that
doesn't change the gradient it just
changes the position so it's really just
the X to the half that I'm worried about
so when you differentiate it what do you
get you get that power coming out the
front and then you reduce the power by
one how's that stellar QK remember we're
differentiating now that you know what
differentiating integrating are one of
the key to the mistakes that students
make is forgetting which one you're
doing is when power going up or is going
down okay you differentiate the inside
what happens to the outside it's just an
object that's been cubed so I'm going to
multiply by the power which is 3 and
then what am I gonna do to the power it
just reduces okay you happy is it ok
this is a bit messy
let's tidy this guy up okay I've got a
half and a threesome alright 3 on to
that square root X plus 1 all squared
where does that belong in the fraction
top bottom positive power that's gonna
be up the top is that ok this X to the
power of negative half really came from
this the original question came in terms
of square roots so rather than leave it
in a fractional power I'm going to
return back to square roots it's a
negative 1/2 so I put down 1 are you
happy with that that look ok all right
excellent